you
you
hello tested
yes I can hear you can't the Barker how
are they today Amy are you worried about
you I I counsel bark roots counsel the
whole I can hear you so right I can al
then Roger that's right that's it we
open run in that somewhere yeah sorry I
just nipped into the kitchen to make a
couple a poor sound like no one was
speaking to you so I dashed back
oh sure busy mommy finish it makya
anyway
okay oh I think just one oh yeah yeah
we're now live chair
kudamon and thanks everyone for coming
I've just got a quick path to read out
for everyone
welcome councillors to this meeting of
the community scrutiny committee this is
a public meeting being streamed live to
YouTube and via the council's website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purposes of the minutes I've been
advised that the livestream is now open
running a friendly reason the public can
no longer hear or see the meeting of the
livestream will adjourn until the
connection has been re-established can
ask the governance officers to explain
the procedure for this meeting
Thank You chair microphones sugar if
meme uses all times unless a member has
been called on to speed by the chair
assist to minimize background noise
members can leave their a cameras
switched on if I feel that in doing so
it's enhanced the debate if the member
was used to speaker and item or joining
me to be pleasing decay list by muting
your microphone and raising the hand you
may also use the chat function to type
speak the chair will then calling you to
speak as appropriate voting will be long
so by acclamation so a simple show of
hands will indicate that the committee
is in agreement
if you are disconnected from the meeting
please try to rejoin as quickly as
possible
if you have any technical difficulties
please contact want to be VC pasilla
taters as indicating indicated on be
meeting Atticus details if you were
about to speak the music always a few
moments thank you very much thank you
thank you Damon add someone apologies
for absence can the government also
please advise if there be any apologies
for absence
no apologies receive care okay
are there any more apologies counselors
who wish to submit apologies on behalf
of absent member please turn your
microphones on
no I don't think anyone has turned a
microphone
declarations of interest if any members
do have any interest to declare please
can you turn your microphone on now I've
not got any one minute slash meeting can
we agree the minutes of last meeting
were a true and accurate record I'm
smooth chair
simple short on summer committee please
I keep it in cream is that everyone
Damon I wasn't there that meeting oh
thank you
you'll have to everyone I'll have to
apologize after pull this Go Go keep
coming from this screen to a different
screen to really to have so there is a
little bit of delay but all these
critics account okay thank you
with regards to the paperwork that we
all should the city be the files that we
have sent in the agenda it refers to
pages for example four to eight nine to
twelve but when you look at those pages
you've got two page numbers on it so
it's a little bit confusing with regards
to going through it so I'm just
wondering if it's possible for the
agenda and the relevant documents to be
displayed on screen okay Damon is that
possible
if you
the time being but we do have some
presentations due to be presented so I
can go back in for the timing it may be
you able to the load V agender all yes
just give me one minute and I'll find it
and get it up
thanks Amy
just being formed in the
by displaying the agenda he will shrink
the images of members to the public and
so I don't know if you want to proceed
sorry can you say that again if we
display the agenda on screen what will
happen is it will shrink everyone and
all the members so it won't be easily
viewed by the public it will just
display the agenda to the public right
they were watching on the livestream so
I just wonder in that case would members
still like but to happen and Casablanca
chair just like to remind officers we
did raise this issue last meeting about
page numbering and they not being in not
being easily followed by members when we
got these different parts so it's a bit
disappointing that it's not actually
been sorted for this time yes okay I
wasn't aware of that issue
councillor Hancock but an easy solution
will be to take the the difference in
the numbering is that the model system
numbers it all the way through the
agenda and obviously this then
individual reports within the pack I can
speak with governance and we can take
those numbers off for future occasions
and just have them I've got good numbers
about how
yeah it is an eggo problems here this we
actually got through it before by happen
in the all of the documents put into one
PDF document and basically we just
worked along the numbers from the PDF I
suggest that in the future we may be
looking at that one smart
okay that's noted is that something we
can look at sir sure
I'm coming charity yet Maxim takes a
little while switch itself on and yes
I'll have a chat with them the
government's often we'll see what we can
sort out
okay thank you move on so with regards
to the agenda being placed on Sookie on
screen I'm happy for it to happen
as they will still be able to hear each
other speaking if anyone has any any
thoughts on that please speak up
otherwise I think it'd be a good idea to
put the agenda if somebody explains
which there which part we're at on the
agenda so that we could switch to be to
the relevant to file then it should be
okay
but patita reference you know the PD of
these is maybe the way both
okay Oh is everyone in agreement we
should have the agenda or do you want to
keep switching back and forward I'm
looking at everyone's faces as know yeah
we're going to put the agenda on yeah
okay if that would be possible please
Amy
that's much better should be on now you
can all say that
yep thank you Amy if you could I don't
have any power over this if you could
keep moving backwards and pause to the
relevant parts that'd be great
yet that's fine yep
don't know my gender three Sauron Rhema
of the committee setting the scene terms
of reference pages nine to twelve and
believe I'm bringing you in yes sir yes
Thank You chair and I just wanted to
provide then you've committed because we
do have some new members along with a
quick reminder of the key points of last
fourteen years and what it can do
Selenia park you'll see that you have a
terms of reference sheet at four a and
and this provides details of what is
within the committee's we know it also
shows what unit scrutiny can a
communities are that's that's useful
because sometimes as many members will
know items can put across more than one
committee for example housing housing
management is with communities but
housing strategies with wealth so it's
just to remind members what's within
within their committee additionally if
there's an item you wish to raise that's
not in this committee as unit you can
raise it relevant chair of the committee
them to consider whether they want to
take it in their committee invite you as
an observer and i can facilitate this if
members won't want to do this at any
time so then just give some key points
lot
what's putin is about it's a mechanism
for backbench counselors and to monitor
performance and you can cut that's
council performance you can use
performance information you can monitor
action plans and also be alert to
service performance on the ground you
can also examine and cabinet proposals
and decisions each meeting you'll see
that you get your four plan of executive
decisions and this is an opportunity to
be alerted to any items that might be
coming up which you might want to wait
some issues on request further
information from from the cabinet side
you can also contribute to policy making
and review and you can do this by being
involved as a consul see if we have any
policies being either brought into being
or being revised or loomed then they
should be offered to scrutiny for
scrutiny consider whether they want to
look at them in the scrutiny of course
there's lots of policies so you can't
cut everything and you just have to
choose the ones - most important that
the things you want to view and you can
also monitor how well our policy is
working and make improvements
recommendations for improvements to
cabinet you can also review issues a
concern say that confirmed members of
the public residents on behalf of their
communities
what it can't do it's not a
decision-making body and it can't make
policies per se it can make
recommendations to mainly cabinet but
obviously all the places as well and get
involved in in policy development the
one thing it does have is the power of
influence and particularly on you're
doing review work obviously if you do
some review work and expect by sound
evidence that's how you help to bear to
influence the decision making on that it
can make informed bekommen Dacians to
cabinet as I say support by the evidence
which I gathers from a mix of
stakeholders including officers partners
in the public and then moving on to the
second bit chair and how the committee
works now how that which works is is
down to the committee decide but in the
past you've tended to want to take it
for two main aspects you decide on an
onion work program up at the end of the
year and you'll see that on the agenda
after acting six we're going to come
back to that and look at the things that
you want to look at during the year
items tend to be contained with mum in
more meeting but not always sometimes it
can spread across a couple of meetings
and are mainly chosen because they
support and add value to the priorities
of the council and help the improve the
services delivers the committee also has
a role in listening to concerns raised
by elect members and members of the
public your work program is a document
that's working progress since dome
it needs a mix of activity we're going
to spare in the year an emerging
emerging issues that you need to respond
to a little bit more about that one
again to that item
it's important to consider what you can
influence and what value your toasters
will add these secondary of your work is
usually the selection of a scrutiny
moving topic and you'll see that's also
on the agenda item six this is normally
done by an in depth review which lasts
the entire municipal year and they say
significant piece of work however given
the circumstances
which we find myself in a moment
alternatively you can use what's known
as a spotlight review method to do very
quick reviews which are very intensive
because they're done over a short period
of time that they allow you to quickly
respond to things the Padawans yet and
report out quicker than the norm in
depth method and at Acton pipe on the
agenda the chair will be imagine you to
discuss and put forward any possible
topics because some situations and I can
also provide advice compensation
activation and I'll just run through the
in-depth living stages chair just so
people can see the difference between
that in the spotlight
feasting an in depth review are you
select the topic after discussion by the
committee in the proposal why do you
should put them to taken and what
outcome you hope to achieve the view
review is then usually scoped by the
chair vice chair alley dice for the
service area that you were viewing
myself and sometimes the proper grip the
review also you can also scope in the
meeting that's a choice for the
committee to make arising from that
stopping at a timetable and project plan
which is essentially your spoken
document will be prepared and brought
back to the committee prefer the
discussion to make sure it's probably
anything that you're wanting to cover
and that you will being that that's the
basis on which I'll proceed over the
next few meetings ending would gather
evidence and two interviews with
stakeholders possible site visits review
of documentation right policies action
plans and performance information at the
end of the year you would an ID all that
information all that occurred and then
formulate recommendations be included in
the speaking rapport which only
submitted consider and family it may
been dating for accepted by cabinet so
these are them pairs of action on part
of the cabinet which the committee will
then receive back and will monitor and
to ensure the recommendations and that's
all I have to say chair so if there's
any questions on that and happy today
thank you sue does anyone have any
questions for spiritual I don't think I
can see everyone on screen so Damon is
anyone raised a hand
thank you I'm just looking at little bit
joined us sunny so how did you scroll
across you can reminisce is a little
enjoying the meeting I think - yes yeah
okay
this shows the right part is that
correct
so seems fill a lot of background in
background noise it's amazing could you
please microphone care Dean is there any
way muting everyone's microphone please
yeah digitize your charities every one
moment Joe I'll be with you in a second
just try this just to get rid of all the
background noise first
I shall believe that everyone's been
muted and can you confirm Lillian as
withers as I correct
yes okay you I can't see it on screen
can you see her on screen
I can't hear ya okay thank you Joe
I believe you indicated to talk canceled
okay Thank You chair just gonna say if
you scroll along the top I'm great on
the laptop I've got an arrow on the top
right uncle if you scroll along then you
can eventually see everybody it's only
six six photos on this pre gotta Lillian
is that that is the last one on here
thank you I don't think we've got that
facility on yeah everyone's shaking
ahead no we don't have that facility
suddenly it's so we'll move on if you go
to the top of the document that's being
shown there's a series of fraud and laws
you can drag that to we're actually
pretty much ruled your screen but it
also brings all of the people that
they're on across the top because you
should be able to see everybody then
okay I'm struggling with that one
suddenly I think I think we'll move on
and try item number five which is
Community Safety Partnership to consider
the work of the partnerships the year
against the partnership plus sue I
believe this is yourself again now if
you consult you scrap we have some
people which I can can read if you're
okay with that yes thank you mistreat
them introduce come here hi Karen thanks
for joining us tonight
it's my start besides him if that's okay
yes please presentation on Community
Safety Partnership is a statutory
requirement at the partnership goes once
a year with an annual report that's the
purpose of our presentation for you
today there's quite a long statutory
requirements around Community Safety we
are required to work with our partners
across the whole of the district for the
patient and detection of crime and
that's why we're here you know exactly
what would be doing in to answer any
questions for you in the room with me in
the moment it's a Green Hill Community
Safety Manager and also sergeant Wilson
from police really officially have any
questions we are also expecting somebody
from DCC to be here he was he was in on
the conversation at the beginning but I
don't see him anymore so he may have
been having technical problems but
you're noticing your cut but it has
provided us with an update a very
comprehensive updates from the County
Council in relation to the work they are
doing their own domestic abuse and I
know we already have an ongoing project
in relation to domestic abuse we thought
that might be useful for you if it does
come back into the conversation we'll
ask you to present that to you but if
not we're more than happy to picture as
best I can and if it's okay I'll pass
you on to say I'm going to aim it you
okay to start the presentation please
for us thank you
good afternoon everyone and favoring
community safety managers for North East
some of you will have had contact with
resource or not so as command says we've
got a statutory requirement this is a
little bit different what I'm doing is
discussing what we've done in the
previous year but I thought in light of
the previous three months that I give
you a bit of an update on how covering
19 has affected communities thank you
the work we've been doing as well so
next slide please
the how have we done this year and
overall crime is on the increase this
has been seen throughout Derbyshire as
well as throughout the country in
Northeast I wish I was increased from
three thousand seven hundred and two and
crimes last year to five thousand donate
this year and violence without injury
has seen a huge increase but you'll be
pleased to know this is not fairly
attributable to do go big 19 the
increases are comparable one bangle
burglary has seen a decrease of 30 grand
year today and again this has been
impacted by coverage 19 and no surprise
to any of those shoplifting his down
central crimes that has been heavily
impacted over the last three months
because shots a majority of them are
being closed and from Motor Vehicles has
decreased by 30 crimes and public
disorder as increased by over three
hundred crimes this last year probably
19 has not helped that situation next
slide please
so what have we been doing we work fully
embedded multi-agency where we've got
case management system now called easy
and this helped to share all our
information on victims and perpetrators
and that is shared with all
all team we've got a fully embedded
action approach and we have weekly
police tasking meetings with all
partners around the table or virtually
as it is now an environment for the
antisocial behavior meet and these are
continued throughout the pandemic just
to make sure that service provision has
hasn't stopped requests from community
trigger our district and across the
county remain low we've had none for not
disturb judiciary which is good and we
support all our victims that I'm social
behavior but who aren't cry the victims
of crime as well so we have that
provision to support people who are
suffering ASB as well as cried because
we recognize that and the social
behavior can have a long-term impact on
people's mental health and well-being
and that's been supported by the office
of the commissioner and we work really
closely with their funded organization
called for M&A who support all victims
of crime social behavior and over the
last three months with the lots of work
with going to County Council the police
and Public Protection on
counterterrorism in two tier authorities
so we've got a plan move forward on that
next when we thank you so what are our
achievements so far we provide hardly
hard men and people the most vulnerable
winning society by one of all that could
be victims of crime victims around
social behavior people with mental
health people were suffering the
domestic abuse any kind of form ability
we will provide a target - the last
financial year we helped seventy-five
people we still might need him to get
equipment out over the last three months
not being quite popular and popular
service
we run cracking crime in banks until
they're specifically tailored to
particular spikes in crime that's not
happened during the past three months
but we do do that we do door knocks in
areas where burglary has been prevalent
etc we provide information to all
residents on how to protect their
property and belongings again over the
last three months that's been more
online and through the news that's gone
out to every household but we are
continuing to provide information we're
also working with neighborhood Watchers
to promote their activity as well as
getting those community messages out
next slide please
antisocial behavior and we provide huge
diversion every work so we work really
closely with
excreting wheels and that PCSOs on
you've designed events in and around the
community you've probably seen quite a
lot of extreme wheels in your particular
areas of Northeast are we sure at the
minute that's been particularly
problematic throughout the pandemic
because extreme wheels staff are
currently furloughed and the beginning
of July with hopeful that that furlough
will cease in July because we've got a
project plans for the summer which is
something called extreme outreach so
that will be taken into consideration
with social distance but also working
with those areas that we're seeing a
spike in anti-social behavior and we are
starting to see that we are starting to
see bits of human nuisance and therefore
that project is really needed we
continue to form to use youth clubs in
and around our area and you can see
there we have CCTV surveillance we call
them lend accounts we've got a
two-thirds in terms of currently we've
got a big way in this
we're not going into people's houses we
are that is on hold but we will be out
there hopefully very soon fitting those
cameras to people who are suffering
crime and anti-social behavior and we
hopefully have got a project with
Solheim Theatre Company and going out
into all secondary schools
hopefully in autumn depending on when
schools go back and that's on crack the
violent crime and another big piece of
work that will at then go in is Arkham
housing not Wingfield it was a big piece
of work last year where we did and we
were part of six closure orders for
Arkham house that's video and we're
continuing to have issues so we're
adopting the multi-agency approach of
working with that next slide that is our
s the interventions and enforcement so
we did we do die imaginary with young
people and we also do enforcement as
well potentially well most of it is not
on young people as you can see our
acceptable behavior contracts today
we've got seven they're generally on
sixteen years of age and under and that
then moves to community protection
warnings community protection fixed
penalty notices and you can see there's
quite a number of those that we observed
over the last 12 months in the last 12
months we've got six closure orders and
we've got one potential pending which
was down to drugs and social behavior
we've got three criminal behavior orders
pending two that were working on at the
minute and one we are waiting for crown
court sentencing hoping that they will
attach the CBO to that we were really
closely with regional homes and other
registered social landlords on tenancy
warnings and ten
Regus due to anti-social behavior that
works really well and we do them we
started to work with some private
landlords on community protection
warnings I'm not quite sure that the
legislation have been translated private
landlords in the fact that they are
responsible for their tenants behavior
and community protection warning is an
easy way of reminding the landlord that
they are responsible for their tenants
quite a lot of work with that over the
last year and like I've just said we
have over the past weeks seen an
increase in nuisance that be minimum
toes kissing groups with no social
distance and in breach of urban laws
without damaged noise and perception of
anti-social behavior and they're the
kind of things that we hope that the
extreme outreach project will start to
work on and it will come as no surprise
that over the last three months we've
done quite a number of safeguarding
referrals and that's two adults and two
young people so we're doing quite a lot
of partnership work on that next time
these women mean we remain committed to
working with people and supporting
people who are suffering domestic
violence and domestic abuse so we
promote and work really closely with the
old foundations of victims of domestic
abuse is not seen the increase that we
we would have expected on curb it which
is good cause that's all relative if you
are suffering domestic abuse and you're
in in it in a relationship went a lot
down with some per day so what we've
done is we've done quite a lot of
promotional with getting information and
advise people on the website on the
internet as well as purchases in
supermarkets when there were any shots
that were
and overall we've seen in 2% increase in
the volume of domestic abuse where
they've caused service joing lockdown
compared to the same period last year so
it is low but we continue to put that
message out for hate crime
we've got CCTV as well as information
and advice for people who are suffering
thugs and alcohol our own awareness and
violence we work with in schools and
youth clubs and other statutory agencies
we're looking to put in a session at
every second school on our district
regarding knife crime and violent crime
and we're working with the police and
we've got another potential closure or
deployment this next coming year inside
these communication and it's important
to get our message out there so we
provide a lot of information to people
through cracking crime events through
our websites at the moment because
that's our medium we want to take
doorknobs to provide reassurance to
people when we're able to when we're and
also gather hearsay informational calls
and we disseminate information regarding
social behavior and crime eyeballs
through the media and websites and
community consultations thanks like
these so how I was covering 19 effective
crime and anti-social behavior northeast
Derbyshire
as of the 7th of June and I know this is
a little bit out of date now there was
two one 2330 cases of go green with in
Derbyshire northeast had considerably
higher levels of courage than the rest
of the county and during the week ended
the seventh of June occur because of
service northeast a Bashar remained
quite high
next slide please verse 23 hate crime
33 half crimes and 15 hair incidents
during them that the week of the seventh
of June and that was a 33% reduction in
hair crime compared to the same period
last year
and that included them some of the some
of the times when there were protests
across the county so we are seeing a
significant problem with order offenses
as we said before have increased during
lockdown we did expect this and you can
see the percentages there again
shoplifting is decreased we expected
this what we have seen ourselves in the
police is an increase of never dispute
since like now some of them we knew and
we knew were women above all be
exacerbated by love others the new to us
and so we've spent quite a lot of time
working on those next I please and
planning for this financial year it's
been slightly harder to plan until we're
fully out of lockdown so we've got quite
a bit of project planning to do when we
are fully out with love we're still
thinking up and reacting to issues
brought about by urban 90 but it is
business as usual for us contact with
creations are currently suspended due to
lockdown but we are planning and writing
statements for call application when we
are able to get back in court we want to
launch the extreme outreach projects and
again once this X between will supper
out with further would be able to do
that
we continue to target harden and we've
got a CCTV waiting list with what the
Salt Mine theater gourmet hurtfully that
will be back in schools in the bottom
and there is a new police and crime
Commissioner plans 2021 so that may
potentially have an impact on our
funding we're not sure yet
when we move to questions can I just
passed Alex sergeant Wilson it just got
a few things thank you very much so yeah
just to add to the information that
phase Dumas wanted to give a bit of a
outline of how that translates into the
policing side of things
so from an 18-point we weren't very
closely with that Community Safety
Partnership and the housing providers
and what we tried to deliver at this
times the three pillars of policing the
pollak from a neighborhood policeman
community engagement crime prevention
and long term problem solving but for
the land with the priorities set by the
Community Safety Partnership and the
police authority in relation to the
written for about child abuse the child
sexual exploitation modern slavery
domestic violence organized crime
cyber-enabled crime and counterterrorism
we consumer like we're trying to raise
our response in terms of the positive
part as well which fella
since the austerity measures are widely
and the way that we trying to implement
that is by using what's called
neighborhood profile so what that means
is the information that we already know
in relation to our key partners
important stakeholders in point and
members a public that we can rely on for
information assistance then we've also
pull out of the use of what a cop -
earlier defending the end of that one
and attached value what's called tarbush
you're talking just prior to lockdown
and northeast are because the lead in
the county in basically knocking on
doors in areas expect on the reason I
was allowing them to say our profiles
and what
you need to call me Jonathan sorry
Jonathan my mute mute thank you
apologist can you hear me now yes we can
again so I did send for a presentation
by understand you probably pressed the
time so and by all means if you
distribute that for people's reference
and particularly there was wanting some
information around domestic abuse
services and the changes we've seen in
the V commissioning so extent through a
briefing document on that from a
domestic abuse manager Allison boys so
again that can be disseminated for
people to look at and then I've put my
email contacts on the presentation I
send specific questions on follow up by
all means they can come through to me
and I can get them answered from a dodge
point of view just a briefly from one a
Community Safety Partnership we recently
gone through a consultation process
about resetting the targets which we
have two on a volunteer basis our main
priorities we are maintaining them have
been some new areas of business we we're
going to kind of add on to it and that's
looking at and what's been doing from
central government around Serious
Organised Crime and where community
safety partnerships fit in with that but
also looking at
so I'm just I'm where I'm at yes so it's
no nice crime including county lines and
also serious violence strategy which
have both been driven from central
government
what's also come out from that
consultation is two strands of how we
want to do our business which is a
preventative and early interventions
model and also being guided by better
use of data and better partnership and
information sharing so again that's all
in the presentation but I've not really
specific to add and I'm happy taking
questions as well but anything comes up
okay thank you
and does anyone have any questions about
what we've just
yeah so counselor my training
thank you and thanks Fay that
presentation was really good and really
helpful I've just done a quick question
because both counts Carolyn running from
our lady myself we we did speak to
extreme wheels just before the New
Year's wanting that we were you know
quite keen on doing was seein if we
could get them to our area in a concern
of suggest to try and help get some of
the you know some of the youngsters off
the streets rear like so I was just
quite interested I know that obviously
with the pandemic that's probably you
know throwing things in the air with
regards to the summer do we is there
anything in the parent line looking
forward to winter so probably more
September onwards unmeaning yeah and for
extreme we have to find a suitable venue
that can take some of their equipment I
know that has done that before we can
you know it will be considered in there
in the area hopeful a directory you may
reach over the summer period we're going
to get them to go to the hot spot so the
hot spot areas would be killa Marsh
Bennington Glen across in Charlie Park
and other areas is that come upon our
course the service during during love
that so we are starting to plan for that
we were just going to keep our fingers
crossed that they come out of furlough
on the 7th of July 6th or 7th thank you
cheers yeah cute and Kosovo uh yeah
thank you I just wanted to say what one
thing that surprised me was the amount
of where you say this six houses that
have been what was the term not knock
down it was more than I worked with so
it was
than I was expecting actually but at
least it goes to show that you are
taking things like that serious
seriously what one thing I wanted to
know was about working with written old
homes it's there any pressure put on
tenants if there is an anti-social issue
in the community locally by other the
tenants or anyone actually living in the
property with them yes everybody who are
anyone else I mean I knew three nodes as
an example because I work very closely
with them and they are one of the best
registered social work with they have a
very strong tendency agreement and Rick
Mills run that tenancy agreement to the
letter so that if anybody in a property
is caught was in antisocial behavior or
any visitors to that their property of
course in antisocial being they are
responsible for that behavior and action
will be taken so we work really closely
with them so it could be anything from a
tendency warning and perhaps a community
protection warning from me it would all
depend on the severity of that
antisocial behavior we can move straight
to notice of intent to see possession if
we deem appropriate to do that and we
have really regular meetings with people
we have weekly with the police and we
have them by ones that are ASG meetings
that are fully integrated and I can say
that they do deal with all that
antisocial behavior really well I wish
every other registered social landlord
would do that but yeah thank you thank
you thank you Roger
does anyone else have any more questions
or comments
a bokken Thank You chair couple of
phrases that they use in their report
which I thought was very comprehensive
what I didn't understand what the phrase
is out I think one was community
targeting and the other words target
hardening could you just explain what
what you mean by those please do you
mean community trigger that was a
tribute of sorry yeah community trigger
is brought in in 2014 through police and
what that was is to ensure that
organizations are held to account so if
if somebody is persistently complaining
about anti-social behavior to the police
to ourselves or to their registered
social landlord or wherever and they
don't feel like they are getting
anywhere they can complete some in work
it's on our website it should be on
every Community Safety partnerships
website across the country and what we
do is we chair a meeting and bring
everybody together to look at their
complaint and how we can address that
better so hopefully you can see that the
Northeast our Bishop in particular we
aren't getting those qualifying
conflicts through community trigger
because we address our anti-social
behavior early and we we've got the
victims of the heart of everything we do
and target hardening is a lot of
hardware in my office if you like for
people who are suffering crime and
anti-social behavior that can be
something as small as a little window
alarm or dummy CCTV we've got a whole
array of kit and what happens is if the
police go out and they see a victim of
crime they get contact with us or if
you've got anybody
you feel like they need to be seen by
yours we will go visit them and we look
at that property to make sure it says
object hardened as possible to make them
feel as safe okay thank you
cancel booking to answer your questions
really
I believe you're next
okay thank you for that hey more of a
comment really I can't speak highly
enough of failure net even and now they
work together this multi-agency working
I've had first-hand experience as as
were alluded to with this outcome house
in Wingfield and it has been a difficult
on that but I've also had experience pre
with previous to that obviously we're
ignored and stuff and I can I can assure
everybody that how all the agencies work
together through this Community Safety
Partnership is fantastic honest I've
been blown away we I think sometimes
counselors can get frustrated because it
takes a time to deal with things because
there's a process that have to go
through you know you can't evict
somebody at the whim you have to have
all the legal documents book Fae and all
the people associated with that
Community Safety in my experience have
been fantastic and now they communicate
with the community and between each
other has been really good so I just
want to stress you know I put my support
behind what they're doing and hopefully
we can carry on with that because it has
been really a real positive thing I
think thank you
thank you if anyone else has any
comments or questions I think no yes yes
Lily and David Hancock we've got the
random Tory year Kevin Yap tree okay can
only see Roger
Oscar Joe and obviously current Jeff and
painted you've got the Rams up I can see
on my screen
yes council Hancock I think Jeff's been
waiting long but to be fair Kevin so
I'll let him go first
very kind of you I mean personally I've
never been short on confidence with
Community Safety Partnership I've seen
the work first and a be chair of that
committee a few years ago it was
brilliant to work with them and I've got
to say it must be difficult just to
carry on the work that they do it oh I'm
pleased to see that the purple issue
it's still on the ball in reference to
the situation in north we build that
correspondence this morning with biggest
that problem and it looks as though once
again it's a successful outcome on
behalf of the community from this
community Community Safety Partnership
funny point of view I think plan is
going to be very difficult again coming
back to the circumstances well ever
discovered 19 problem is on but yes just
as a pre bit to it do we expect the Rye
is in the problems as the Pacific the
lockdown comes off um and from position
of the helm Foundation and domestic
abuse it's suggesting that rise of two
percent I start asking yourself
questions because women but a lot we've
got people that the forced stayed or
some of those people will work in I'm
getting away to where else are
perpetrators of domestic violence
they're generally associated
people with the money and it's an
association with the done after alcohol
and what a lot there was concealed I'm
just wondering if it expecting yeah rise
in that problem
the other thing being its somebody's in
lockdown with an abusive partner does he
not follow that they may have problems
being able to communicate with the
police stand and report any problems
that they may have and he could be you
know once again a release of that when
lockdown and an escalation in reports
and calls okay the corona buyer is path
of another pass over to sergeant Wilson
in relation to domestic abuse so we've
got some coronavirus surprises we are um
part of what's called the lrf which is
the Brazilians forum and the NRF started
meeting daily the gold group the
strategic group and then eventually that
was reduced three times a week and then
now it's once a week and that group is
responsible for the phone coordination
around the coronavirus crisis everything
from the NHS and the social care aspects
fight for the community cohesion and any
issues around the regulatory enforcement
so as a partnership we have been
ensuring that tensions are kept to a
minimum that we are aware they are
pockets attentions then at the beginning
most of our work centered around
regulatory services where environmental
health team we're responsible for
ensuring that when we receive very
frustrated complaints and businesses
still being over there you'll be aware
that some of the pups are still open in
the very beginning we dealt with that
very very quickly with police colleagues
to make sure that those frustrations and
tensions didn't continue an equally now
as things are starting to open up we are
working very very closely as well but
all of that we're very aware that some
neighbors are now getting really hacks
off with with noise nuisance barking
dogs and some may be disputes is
starting to boil over so we work very
closely with colleagues and all all of
those things and the local resilience
forum receives that they
around tensions on a weekly basis to
make sure they're all under control so
you're right counselor Lily we have got
quite a big agenda around home in
nineteen it's not just straightforward
as the things that you hear on the
government briefing is very very complex
and we are trying to keep on top of all
of that we will continue to do so
particularly as we go into July where
potentially some of the perhaps might
open up again if they allow us to do
that and infancy meters or get reduce to
1 meter etc we've got a lot of work to
coordinate on High Street running people
back out meeting families etc and some
of that does come with some criminal
activities and nuisance and social
behavior and community tensions that
we're doing as a partnership very
breasts Rachel we know where that isn't
and we're doing our best to help we're
also quite a big agenda around mental
health with isolation being a very big
factor to that as a district council
we're trying to work with as many
partners as we can and also our
community support in continues to work
with our residents who are suffering
from loneliness and isolation are
adjustments that society will also in
relation to Mexico views yeah in
relation to the do so I think these
recognize that that would be a further
risk area given the people asked as
require our products teen endorse
together with other behind them across
the county in relation to what we call
evidence LED submission submissions to
CPS oh and he calls for service we'll
get to addresses should we be from the
victims themselves or any third party
the officers are instructed to be more
stringent in their investigation behind
using body-worn video footage towards
CPS any sure in the house-to-house
inquiries have gone across you know with
neighbors and people across their own
amamiya using the telephone recordings
or the contact methods as part of the
investigation
should we get any recourse
you using previous information
previously with other addresses
telephone need any medical records any
anything else that we get in relation to
that what we previously would have
called in victimless provocation that's
the right thing because there's always
deleting
so we're referring to it as evidence
when submissions massive emphasis on
that furthermore is the multitude of
reporting methods that were cut and
player one zero one nine nine nine
the online submissions in the social
media reports in as well so on that
social media platform as well we are
making clear we're using what's called
think family there's a method for
contacting us and then also we went on
from what Karen said about the year
planning for the Kobe 19 restriction
being lifted
seriously I've done some Facebook live
videos this morning and on social media
just trying to clarify as the week
happens coming up explaining the new
legislation around the new year the
lockdown bubble and hopefully adding a
bit of clarity the feedback that I have
about seven far is that that information
has been quietly quietly it just there
is the the perception that locked down
pretty much over and people are doing my
have anyone but we is the from the
police and things are very much geared
towards the for ease the education the
being coherent and as opposed to the
here we going to the enforcement side of
things so when I'll still trying to
advise an in college okay thank you
girl so Hannah Cole did you still want
to speak yes
thanks thanks chair of this there's two
two elements actually the last one kind
of picks up on on just point there it's
positive that our domestic abuse is is
lower than we expected but that kind of
rings the obvious alarm bell is
is there more going undetected than
we're aware of obviously going forward
we've got the the seemingly lifting on
sports which we know historically
there's a correlation between sporting
events and increase in domestic violence
so really want to be confident that that
kind of bit is being on it's being
checked checked over the second part
actually is is echoing Nigel's I've had
work with fake on quite a few instances
and her team are absolutely brilliant
and the risk of creating more work for
her I know that they have done in in my
ward Faye and Rick now actually come out
and on from public public meetings and
explain their work and they were very
very well received and actually put a
lot of confidence I think in what the
council does so I can't speak highly
enough of the work that she and she and
her team and they get but if we're being
honest that the multi agents thing has
its hiccups but when you're working
across across things that is inevitable
things do slip through the netball
overall I think I think that the work is
sterling but so that that praise aside I
just obviously want come back and make
sure the that we are picking up and
we've got the mechanisms in place to
pick up on domestic violence's and
potential increases as the as the field
keeps changing from a police point of
view we don't really see a two percent
small two percent arises and success we
we would have expected a lot more
reporting which you like the stringent
methods have been place book we said
they're not going to remain completely
with the fact that we've only seen a two
percent right that's not something that
that makes us happy we want it in going
more and more reporting so that we can
tackle it properly so I can assure you
and I'm gonna restaurant hours of that
okay well County perspective on to us
could be services yes sure so I think a
lot of really valid is potentially we've
got issue of under reporting currently
lots of reasons and potentially have
lockdown ease as we might start to see a
sudden increase of votes concerns the
poor which are submitted for big share
this sort of is but we've not seen those
concerns related national level of an
increase yet but there have been two
bids we've submitted to central
government funding barbecue incentive
partnership to get some additional
funding to be prepared for this
potential increase coming through and
that's going to be then providing more
resources to deal with this issue as it
was probably coming the system the
agreement which is confirmed county
council level is that they will under
the like that funding bids at the moment
so whether it's successful or not that
money will be in place to deal with any
concerns as they come through
okay thank you Jonathan if there's no
further questions or comments I shall
let thank you all very much for your
attendance
thank you very much yes no problem thank
you can would anyone like a professional
break or is everyone okay to carry on
you have to put your mind carry on
have a break please two minutes yes sir
a couple of minutes and then everyone
come back is everyone okay with that
yeah yeah
yeah yes Osgood okay thank you
okay if everyone could mute the
microphones will will proceed title
number six which is selection of
selection of Scruton review not to
discuss and select topic than preemies
and believe we had a sheet sent out suit
can you confirm if we've had any back at
all so are you still there let's just
check
still there I don't know if you there
soon but happy return all the quietly as
the counselor comma Sweeney did have a
suggestion and if I can also mention
that I chair can you hear me I can't see
I think someone else is microphones on
them yes
yeah yes
you've got to love technology yes I can
hear you sue she's behind you Kevin
watch it there are twice a me
yeah yeah and one of the reasonable
tortured yet one of us malfunctioning so
I'm just sorting your burlap box can you
hear me now yes I can sir apologies for
that chair and wonder that I had got
both laptops because I can see all the
members on one and I can then also see
who's talking on the other one of them's
just gone down with the connection so
I'm now on the apologies
thank you I haven't had any received
back on the forum that was sent out and
I know that counselor drama drina's may
have a suggestion he wants to talk about
I also did send out some information to
senior officers to us whether they had
any items they'd like the committee to
consider for review and the only one who
hacked back was from Steve fluent the
head of service who looks after waste a
street scene and he suggested something
gone around the impact of Kovach 19 I
think possibly he was talking perhaps
about the impact on income because you
know the service covers a wide range of
areas some of its generating come so it
may have been around that but if the
committee are interested in that I can
get further information for the next
meeting but it's really down to if any
members of the committee have any year
suggestions chair okay well
councillor Gomez really you need to get
back to sue so I feel that you'd go
first
thank you
yes so my suggestion it was probably not
one to necessarily take 12 months on but
it was to look at how we're doing as a
across the community through the
pandemic so looking at things such as
obviously you know make sure that will
maintain in any green spaces that we own
are we making sure you know looking at
things such as the community supporting
which you know they've done a great job
on so just having a lot more in-depth
into that and I know one of the things
which people have raised with me bins in
general so the I think there's been a
few well one or two cases in our area
where bins haven't been acted and not as
in bins of people's houses but the
public bins so I just thought it might
be quite useful for us to just to dig a
bit deeper into that okay thank you it
was one topic I'd like to look at and it
was the mental and mental health mental
health of our and younger residents
so I've kids myself and I understand
it's difficult I'm not been in school
for four months I'd like to look at in
terms of getting them back into I
believe mental health and physical
health is both closely linked so what
the council is doing around those sorts
of areas and looking into parks and
again green spaces that sort of thing so
that's that's something I'd like to look
at but obviously it is a committee I'll
open it up to everyone else as well
chair can I just turn that item that
you've just raised first and then kind
of meeting yet but I have no
organization are looking at mental
health but obviously this committee made
me look at it from a different focuses
as you've just outlined but just so you
were aware that that's something they're
considering okay thank you sir I don't
think this coded nineteen thing can
ignore since I'm an a master in effect
on the community and I think it does
affect the younger generation as well as
well as the older generation but I'd
like to see what the council is able to
do especially with schools being off
something around our younger residents
I mean I'll put it out to everyone
and everyone else things yeah you you
chat box yeah accounts only just gonna
love with it the idea was regards to
kids and you know people that suggest
that maybe could look at the services
video services in general throughout
northeast area and and see where we can
make some improvement both for a local
health point of view and from a physical
health point of view
um if too many kids sorta set about
doing very little complain of Earth on
the phone whatever and a lot of physical
activities have been overlooked maybe we
could start and have a look at some
areas of their in general and see what
maybe we as a council can promote with
regards to both physical and mental in
the USA thank you Jeff Oscar then mr.
Hancock okay yeah I was gonna say yeah
with regards to mental health I mean
Andy mental health ambassador for our
parish council and have been doing quite
a lot with mental health during my first
year in office so I would definitely be
more than willing to have a lot more
into the mental health impacts
especially with young people I mean I
did a survey not too long ago about
month ago during the lockdown with
people across Derbyshire and we had to
look at the results I mean I'm more than
happy to send across su the report that
we put together on that to be circulated
just if anyone would be interested but I
think it would be very beneficial I like
to work too much we look at that so yeah
more more than happy to to go ahead with
that suggestion chair
Thank You counselor Hancock thanks chair
I actually support Oscars as well so and
we have got capacity for both of these
well certainly I agree with supporting
the young people's mental health health
issues
you
or bit but the main thing is is with
other authorities so I'm just taking a
better advice of what exactly our role
will be within that so well that's what
I'm asking yeah thank you I mean
obviously this is a discussion we've had
chair about recently about this subject
and of course many of these things are
things that are doing at county level
but the committee is earth in a path
take in the view that they are prepared
to look at such issues from a district
point of view and in fact we have done
reviews like with you'll see later when
we talk about the work program you've
Russian action plan coming back on
domestic abuse which obviously County
does a lot on we also did a general
mental health review some somewhere ago
looking at how a we deliver services not
specifically targeted at children and
again that's you know done by other
partners but they can make a just take
the view that they can look at what the
district counsel does because we do do
things we may not have the lead role on
it that we can do some things and also
if there's particular things that you're
concerned about those issues that you
can raise with the lead authorities you
can't force them to do that but you can
try and influence their decision on it
thank you sir so thanks for that so and
now Matt be if if you think that that's
someone we can influence that's great
thank you if I put it to everyone then
if we do something along the lines of
childhood obesity mental and mental
health mental health and well-being and
I'm seeing some I can only see a few
year I can see six you've got a thumbs
up that's fantastic and also can see
Jeff
yeah good lovely it's nice to get you an
agreement and counselor
sorry I was just a good
I'm just saying yes they're in agreement
that's great
did you want to talk yes yeah sorry
and I just wanted to check what you
wanted to do about this obviously and
widened it to obesity and mental health
which is a much bigger subject but I was
just wanting to mention sculpin usually
we do this outside of the meeting but I
know growth the stair would beYOU have
decided to do it within the meetings so
that more people can contribution
obviously given that we're doing things
virtually because I think you'll need to
scope that with a lead offset and see
how that fits in because that what if
you remember we once considered doing a
be scary last year and we had such a
heavy work program we couldn't do that
as well I think we'd need to stop it and
see how big that review was and then you
could take a decision whether you focus
on both or whether you just focus on the
mental health thing but that's for a
later date I just wanted to flag it up
okay that's something we can narrow down
at scoping yes and it's a case of where
do you want to do that in a small
informal group or whether you want to do
it in in the next meeting chair okay I
know I think I think it's nice to get
everyone in agreement and that's it the
kind of area we want to go towards so
I'm happy to put it on for the next
meeting everyone to go away and have a
little think about what areas they'd
like to look at and then bring them all
back we can narrow it down and target
where we want to go okay thank you
the other topics I can see one end up
yes Africa just thank you I was just
gonna say would would you like me to
send the report over to sue that we did
on general mental health I'm just
thinking it might be a useful bit of
information for the committee to look
out when they're you know thinking for
the next meeting you know what sort of
areas etc they want to consider yes
thank you I think if we get everything
gathered together before the next
meeting that'd be a good idea no worries
I'll send that to to suit to be
circulated them thank you castor Barker
yeah Cheers good I'll just just wanted
to what what do you want to get out
Donny as a chair you you've suggested it
I just wondered you know what like so
Center beginning about what what's
what's your outcome I just wondered just
just just so I know where I'm that we go
in in same direction if you know what I
mean I just
just a bit authority really yeah I mean
that's all yeah for me it's it's been a
culture change really with children
staying at home or being stuck on TVs
and computers and and I think with the
schools being closed they've lost a lot
of physical activity and getting out and
doing stuff I want to look if there's
anything the council can do whether it
be maybe I played Park those kind of
things that's what I'm looking towards
doing somewhere that hasn't got it would
it would need it that's what I want to
do and I want o the youth the future and
I want to make sure they've got got
facilities to use that's that's my
thinking
I mean it's we're all here together so
he sought to everyone really that's the
kind of area I'm I think physical health
and mental health are very closely
linked thanks for that yeah got the idea
counselor Gomez rainy so it's bit of a
pain when you're trying to amuse this
out I was just going to say you and I
think there's there is definitely
potential for us to do a lot of positive
I mean um so just going back to Fay
greens presentation and they spoke about
things such as the extreme outreach over
summer and I know that lack of said I've
looked into mental health and we've done
a few bits through the parish council
and I think there's definitely one one
thing that we you know probably want to
look at is you know the these schemes
such as the extreme outreach you know
there anything that we can do with
regards to working with them mental
health charities whether that be local
or nationally so I think very positive
about this to be honest because you know
it's something that I'm quite passionate
about and yeah there's there's
definitely there's a lot of good
opportunity I would say that could come
from this okay thank you does anyone
else have any other topics you'd like to
put forward at all please bear in mind I
can't see you all okay first there's
nothing else then M so we all right for
the next meeting and scope it further
then yeah thank you Charlie waits I
receive some with my issue and I'll let
him touch I'm all sort out how we really
populate the scoping document Thank You
Shane so for move on to item number
seven which is forward one of the of
executive decisions 15 yeah okay sorry
sorry I did daddy sorry we made you know
a that Oscar said you know he got an
idea about we've seen oe/oe parking that
one for a bit that part
and stuff green spaces and then teen
bender these I will leave mean that one
Oscar will bring you in on this one
I always go to South yeah I think we've
decided to partner I'm happy to go where
observe with the the mental health I
think that all filfil as as Diaries or
pin off okay thanks okay that's fine
item number seven which again it's the
fourth planet of executive decisions
15th made 15th to June pages 15 to 17 to
consider the fall of plan executive
decisions sir I believe this is just for
noting is that correct
you said this is a document that comes
every meeting and it's just to alert
members key decision
in case members have been generally
speaking I think members generally get
to know what's going on anyhow but it's
considered best practice to just have
the document delivered the committee's
can make sure that they don't miss
anything okay thank you sue does anyone
have any comments no okay thank you
item number eight screw scrutiny work
program pages 18 to 22 to consider the
work program for the community scrutiny
committee does anyone have any comments
I believe we sent out the wrong dates
for the first on the first one did mr.
got a 2090
yeah we've had bonbon day chair what you
having I did send out revised and
updated work program so you'll you
should have that in front of you which
has the correct dating to say obviously
we had a conversation about what was on
this work program and I have updated it
with those suggestions from from that
meeting so if members just want to look
down the very state's and obviously I
will read you get to fit in the review
work but if you can look at the other
items on their own and decide whether it
is something that they want to add to
that Jake and I just government ain't
got time to topic in today I'm just
going to rotate says 12th of July which
is assume me what is the proper day well
in actual fact the next meeting after is
the femme August so that's the meeting
that the 12th of July shouldn't be there
it's December we can do it honest or
newphew on Nigel that will not look at
it it's 29 that's even better
it's John travel a thing of the past
that's the thing dude which brings got a
for next question for everyone because
the next meeting while we're on the work
program the next meeting is due to be
Friday the 7th of August and generally
we don't have any meetings in August as
a council which I do understand and I
know there's been a curve in 19 and but
I'm happy to do it on the 7th of August
but again I'm also happy to do it on
Friday the 31st consider as long as
there's no other meetings on if it
doesn't clash with anyone so again would
give you your August back but I'm happy
to do either I can leave it or I can
move it I'm happy to do either what
everyone decides
yes Kate if I'm truthful the last day of
the month is always a busy day for me
work wise anyway got to be honest I've
never been subscribed to this shutting
down for all this business anyway to me
it's a normal once you just carry off
catch the vodka yep so I think
everyone's happy to keep it in August as
I correct
yeah no problem so move on to item
number 9 which is additional urgent
items if any to do any other matter
which the chair of the meeting the sort
of the opinion should be considered as a
matter of urgency
okay just before you go on to that kind
of dispenser on your work program you'll
notice on this temple' because you've
got your residential parking with you
which was the review that you undertook
last year now as you know you have the
draft report that and you've asked me to
send it to the committee after this
meeting and so it's just two litters to
that so that we can finalize that report
out the next meeting yes thank you
all will still be an online meeting on
Sunday August yes I believe it will
unless there's any drastic changes
that's okay for you yeah yeah yes it's
fine for me I just wondered when we're
getting back to going back to meetings
all together in a room I know no one's
got a crystal ball but I just wondered
if lockdown at ease totally by then
whether we would make bucket
I think that's for a more important
meeting there will be meetings held that
are more important hours to discern and
I think Roger okay I just have a great
Roger that one we don't we go thank you
let me just check here
items I don't think anyone's got any a
there's no comments facilities if if we
do get back to normal it is just been
suggest has anything been done yet about
the the Luke system in the in the main
room in the council chamber
yes I can answer that
I think Damon will be the best one
perhaps to answer that because obviously
I'm not in in the counter building at
all at the moment I wasn't aware it
should happen there may be more today
than I am okay we don't we do have Damon
still thank you yeah tomorrow standing
there was some work taking place I know
you would be somewhere commend you as he
was and restore some problems I
understand council only so I'll check
home on that one boy I am aware from
work has taken place in the past couple
homes okay thank you
number 10 which is date of time date and
time of next meeting which is the 7th of
August at 1:30 which roll agreed is is
acceptable which the
you're very much for your attendance and
I hope to see you on the seventh
okay thank you
you